hey there all you Halloween errs I am
Walter been a Z AK and welcome back to
October top 5 so many of you have been
asking about this series so just call me
the mailman because I'm delivering in a
big way starting right now with the best
episode breakdown are you afraid of the
dark a question that has meant a lot to
a legion of fans since the early 1990s
this series aired a total of 7 seasons
and 91 episodes the original run ended
in 1996 after just five seasons but was
revised in 1999 for two more I did
discuss it a bit in my video of the top
5 best 90s Nickelodeon shows and make no
mistake about it Nick in the 90s would
not have been as strong as it was
without this show upon rewatching I was
pleasantly surprised with how well are
you afraid of the dark held up it
excelled in what it was good at which
was being a scary show for kids while
still being interesting enough to hold
the attention of teenagers and even some
of their parents there are some
legitimately great episodes of this
Canadian produced anthology series so
let's take a look a submitted for the
approval of the channel awesome society
I call this countdown the top 5 best are
you afraid of the dark episodes number 5
the tale of train magic from season 4
I'm gonna say this right off the bat
this is a horrible title they could have
gone with numerous other ones that would
have been represented this story if I
were to make a top 5 worst are you
afraid of the dark episode titles this
might make the list however the actual
episode is one of the best Frank tells
the tale of a boy named Tim who has
recently lost his father a train
conductor and is not dealing with it
well he's obsessed with trains and wants
to be just like his dad a veteran
conductor appears to him on an old set
of tracks near his house and the
mysterious train man eventually gives
him a special toy train car the young
boy soon finds out the horrifying
details behind these peculiar happens
this definitely isn't the scariest
episode in the series but it's just
creepy enough with a very strong story
not to say it isn't a little cheesy but
I'm a sucker for an effective
sympathetic character and Tim absolutely
fits that description the kid just lost
his dad and is trying to hang on to
something from him
Tim's father's friend cap looks out for
the young boy and when that strange
conductor starts showing up cap explains
who he might be train crashed
a lot of folks died accusing the
conductor Reynosa but Assam you dug his
body out of your Rick still had to watch
it
this episode has a concept that shows up
in the series a few other times that
being the main character getting sucked
into a smaller version of an actual
place in this case the toy train car
transports Tim onto a ghost train
[Music]
I won't give the rest away but it works
great as a little ghost story there is
something kind of eerie about old trains
and abandoned tracks this episode
covered that well with some good
character development let's chug along
at number four number four the tale of
the crimson clown from season three
scary clowns are very popular right now
so this episode fits right in Gary tells
the tale of two brothers Mike and Sam
who are out trying to get their mom a
birthday present Sam the bratty younger
brother treats Mike like crap and steals
the money his older brother was going to
use to buy his mom's present and buys a
videogame for himself
mike tells Sam to stop misbehaving or
the crimson clown will get it what
started out as a story to scare Sam
turns out to be a lot more real than the
troublemaker ever thought I grew up with
bozo so I was never really scared of
clowns but I remember being creeped out
by crimson it's that laugh it's freaking
demented
[Music]
they really play up how much of a little
jerk sammich so when the Crimson clown
haunts him later
you don't feel all that bad for however
it doesn't make it any less creepy
[Music]
I can see this one freaking out little
kids and if you do have a fear of clowns
it's probably still a little scary
[Music]
though
number three the tale of station one oh
nine point one from season five Ryan
Gosling and Gilbert Godfried guest star
in this episode so it's definitely a
star-studded installment Stig tells the
tale of Chris leery a boy who has a
fascination with death and the afterlife
when his brother Jaime locks him in a
hearse to scare this obsession out of
him Chris begins to hear a strange voice
on the radio when he investigates the
station he finds out it's for those who
have passed away and missed crossing
over to the other side he's mistaken for
a dead person and must convince the
clerk there that he's still among the
living this is a really good concept and
the acting is pretty solid from everyone
but the real reason that this episode is
on the list is because of Gilbert
Godfrey he's hilarious in this while
maintaining a little touch of dread boy
if I had a dime for every time somebody
tried to weasel out of day you would
actually do me no good at all cuz I'm
dead why do I need money for what am I
gonna do I'm dead what am I gonna do
white there are jokes in there that went
over my head watching it for the first
time as a kid but our funny as hell now
I don't make mistakes buddy-boy Gosling
isn't the main kid in this one but he's
still enjoyable the cheatin
I'm Daniel carpenter but there's a sense
of urgency for Chris to not be
mistakenly thrown into the afterlife
that kept me interested the entire time
this is a really good episode okay one
more Oh standing quietly one after the
other
why do you suppose that is you tell me
yeah go number two the tale of The
Midnight Madness from season 2 I love
this episode the setting the concept dr.
Fink dink
it's just great Frank tells the tale of
an old-time theater called the Rialto
it's a landmark that shows classic films
but isn't making enough money to stay
open
dr. Fink shows up to change all that he
gives the employees an old silent film
he made called Nosferatu the demon
vampire to show at the theater the movie
is a massive hit and saves the cinema
but when the manager goes back on his
word to show more of Vinc films
Nosferatu comes to life straight out of
the movie screen leaving the employees
to deal with the vicious vampire the
execution on this episode is pretty much
perfect the idea of a movie character
coming to life in the real world isn't
an earth-shattering new idea but it
works flawlessly here
I always thought Nosferatu was unnerving
so seeing a version of Count Orlok pop
up here is pretty freaky I love that he
doesn't make any sound since he came out
of a silent movie and glides instead of
walks great touches we also care about
these protagonists the male and female
employees Pete and Katie are pretty good
Pete especially is given some nice
development in a very short amount of
time
when he went up against us for a to I
was rooting for I have to mention dr.
Vinc as well he's a fan favorite and
appeared in a few of Frank's stories
this is my favorite appearance from it I
couldn't have written it better myself
believe me I've got many many that are
far better than this one can we see some
of those a sequel to this episode would
be fantastic like a lot of you I grew up
loving this show and there are so many
more than just 5 great episodes I really
wanted to talk about but at the very
least I can list them here as honorable
mentions
[Music]
and the number one best are you afraid
of the dark episode is the tale of the
silver site parts one through three from
season seven this is the ultimate story
we finally get to see the midnight
society in a scary tale all their own
when his grandfather unexpectedly dies
Geary the former leader of the midnight
society returns to the group seeking
their help his grandfather left behind a
true story for him that only he would
believe it involves tracking down the
former members of the original midnight
society and destroying an evil charm
called the silver site the group splits
up looking for the original members but
don't anticipate what a dangerous path
they're all on this little saga was
absolutely worth bringing Gary back for
it's ultimately his story
I'm Tucker's brother I used to run these
briefings
[Music]
it looks like you've changed things a
little bit when I always here we
building the war of the midnight society
itself was a great idea having it
basically be a family heirloom that Gary
and Tucker are continuing the legacy of
provided even more background for us to
care about with these characters love
this by the way Dennis in a while
submitted for the approval of the
midnight society I call this story
I will say these aren't perfect episodes
for some reason they felt it necessary
to make a few scenes a little too goofy
the sewer sequences in part 2 almost
killed the vibe what have we here were
you announced the silver site is a fun
eerie and intriguing mystery that proved
to be the series best it's a layered
story and made me want to see the
midnight society have their own scary
adventures more often looking back
though the fact that this is the only
one makes it that much more special
again having Gary return and seeing him
with Tucker one last time was just
really cool as a longtime fan of the
series
[Music]
after watching this and goosebumps
back-to-back I feel like I have a pretty
strong perspective on the strengths and
weaknesses of both shows but which one
is better go ahead and check out a new
video on my personal channel where I
present my thoughts on this question I
want to hear what you guys think what is
your favorite are you afraid of the dark
episode what do you want me to cover
next in the show leave a comment and let
me know to stay in touch like my
facebook page facebook.com slash awesome
walter b and follow along on twitter to
take part in more polls about what may
be covered in the future come back next
week as we take a look at the top 5
worst episodes of this spine-tingling
series
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]